è la tutti ragazzi e benvenute questo
nuovo video io sono qua vj ed oggi siamo
qui in un nuovo blog grazie infinite per
che stiamo per raggiungere un traguardo
assurdo ovvero 100 mila iscritti raga un
traguardo impressionante non mi sarei
mai aspettato una cosa del genere
ragazzi io sono
sono senza parole e ve lo dico ogni
traguardo che faccio vi dico sta cosa
avete le palle piene ma lo dico sempre
raga perché vi giuro ogni traguardo che
arrivò dico non ci posso credere e
invece poi arriviamo con traguardo
ancora più grande e ragazzi io non ho
veramente parole grazie infinite in
moltissimi ragazzi avete chiesto il
fermo posta che devo fare che limite
sarebbe l'indirizzo al quale potrete
inviare i bachi che aprirà nei prossimi
video indirizzo lo scriverò di sicuro
nella pagina di facebook e come non glie
lo trovate nella descrizione quindi se
avete mi piace sulla pagina di facebook
sapete quando metterò al fermo posta
comunque ragazzi la parata della
settimana anche questa volta l'abbiamo
ed è affatto da maria fantastica mio
parere grandissima fine volete che
risponde alle vostre domande scrivete le
qui sotto nei commenti sotto i commenti
di questo video oppure su twitter sotto
l'astag fa vi risponde selezionano ai
commenti anche da lì crimi ragazzi direi
di passare alle domanda lo a pavia
scuola come ti trattavano visto che di
famoso su youtube domanda per il blog
allora a scuola tutti mi trattano come
se fossi un sovrano quindi io vado dal
primo che mi capita e dico tu brutto
maledetto schiantati al muro il mio
onore e loro lo fanno adesso vi do una
dimostrazione
vai
[Musica]
come potete vedere la gente si schianto
al muro se glielo chiedo no vabbè
comunque al di fuori youtube sono un
ragazzo normale o amici anch'io sono un
essere umano respiro
quindi non è che se vado a scuola mi
chiedono tutti gli autografi c'è non è
una cosa così
cosa ti ha portato a diventare lo
youtuber migliore di tagli allora va beh
non mi definisco io tu per migliori
d'italia ma ti ringrazio per il
complimento più che altro il successo
penso che sia dovuto al fatto che ci
dedico molto i miei vi dò io le dico
veramente tanto tempo a ogni singolo
video la gente piace quando si vede che
una persona si diverte a fare quello che
fa bisogna avere pazienza bisogna avere
perseveranza dovete continuare a fare
quello che mi piace fare è ignorare chi
tenta di mettervi i commenti negativi
proprio fate finta di niente perché
quella è gente che tenta di buttarvi giù
e se siete più forti loro dovete
continuare a fare quello che vi piace
fare la gente vi seguirà perché se mi
piace fare una cosa uscirà per forza un
qualcosa di divertente quindi siate voi
stessi può cominciare le vicende domanda
qual è il tuo youtuber preferito alla
ragazze per quanto riguarda gli hutu
bear italiani sono sio che seguo e che
col che fa le traduzioni con google
traduttore
penso che l'ho conosciuto un po tutti
poi io toby seguo tantissimo ho visto
anche di video di dario moccia che stimo
moltissimo come l'ultimo youtuber seguì
buzzard
com sca se si pronuncia così klyuka
yachtique moka o tic monkey più di pai
poi c'è mark player c'è
ce ne sono tanti con qui insomma
youtuber che segue ce ne sono tanti i
quali te lo saresti mai aspettato questo
traguardo
no assolutamente no centomila iscritti
sono una cosa che non mi sarebbe mai
neanche passata per la testa sono
tantissimi non mi sarebbe c'è ma mai mi
sarei immaginato una cosa del genere
quindi ragazzi vi ringrazio per
l'ennesima volta
comunque no assolutamente no ma perché
ti sei tagliato i capelli
comunque se unito il secolo al psg non
smetterò mai di farlo mi sono tali
aspirazioni le innanzitutto i sarà
tagliato i capelli perché non ci vedono
ce li avevo sotto gli occhi non vedono
anche più lo schermo non potevano anche
più far vinto con i miei sono tagliati
per questo ma tanto tranquilli che ci
mettono una mi chiami capelli a
ricrescere quindi siamo condannati all
una curiosità cosa vuoi dire a tutti
quelli che affermano che i compiti di
pine sei uno strumento continua così
allo ragazzi questo è un argomento un po
serio la miss oh fermi un attimo su
questa cosa
allora ragazze su youtube
internazionalmente parlando che brutta
parola che ho detto vabbè ci sono gli
haters gli haters ci sono in ogni canale
di youtube su tutti coeli a chiunque su
youtube gli haters cela anche più di pai
stesso quando vedete il commento di un
iter non cagate lo di striscio perché
così facendo gli date corba voi mi avete
mai visto commentare un'iter no non l'ho
mai fatto mai lo farò perché il modo
migliore per
per farli apparire delle merde e quello
oggi non calcolarli di striscio quando
fanno sti commenti quindi ragazzi non
rispondete mai a coloro che scrivono ste
stronzate ci sono anche altri tipi di e
ting perché molti non si sa non si
fermano a questo ad esempio alcuni
dicono ma vj è raggiunto un successo
incredibile perché ti compri le
visualizzazioni qualcuno afferma anche
che mi copre e visualizzazioni
io sta cosa la prendo come un
complimento perché se qualcuno arriva
veramente a pensare sta cosa significa
che sto veramente avendo successo
quindi ragazzi vi ringrazio di pensare
una cosa una stronzata nel genere perché
mai mi dovrei comprare visualizzazioni
che cazzo di senso avrebbe a parte che
ho scoperto questa cosa prima che si
chiama google adwords o adwords non mi
ricordo la mente è una cosa che tu paghi
cioè io dovrei pagare di tasca mia dei
soldi per essere sponsorizzato da
youtube perché youtube e mettesse in
primo piano per apparire nella home cioè
prati mente ci sono alcuni heiter sia
gli minuti mente di dire pari tutti i
compiti e visualizzazioni stronzata ma
perché il cazzo dovremmo fare una cosa
del genere purtroppo non ho modo di
dimostrarlo perché non ha un account di
google adwords dovrei crearlo appunto
per farvi vedere che
non mi copre visualizzazioni ma non me
lo creo perché non ha più intenzione di
fare una stronzata del genere non mi
comprerò mai le visualizzazioni una
grandissima stronzata però all'inter si
attaccano anche a questo servire queste
sono le tre cose principali che urlo che
scopi più di pai e che mi compri
visualizzazioni tre cose veramente
tristi per provare a metterli in cattiva
luce che non funzionano questo non è un
problema mia ce l'hanno tutti però per
dire è che mi dà fastidio quando voi
rispondete a sta gente qui ragazzi non
mi difende te non me la prendo non sa
sono mai presa non ho sempre continuato
a profitto guardata querelle traguardo
siamo arrivati nonostante ci siano ci
sia qualcuno che tenta di fare lei però
notato anche che alcuni di voi sono
andati a scrivere tipo nel video di
qualcun altro però to copy fa vj perché
fa vj ha fatto che mario tu non lo puoi
fare perchè l'ha fatto parigi e quindi
lo copie basta ragazzi no una cosa del
genere non la voglio neanche vedere non
dite a nessuno non puoi fare questo
videogioco perchè l'ha fatto famiglia in
pazzia c'è ma figuriamoci se io me la
prendo se qualcuno fa un video gioco che
ho fatto io anzi c'è significa che sono
stato d'ispirazione per qualcuno nel
caso avesse visto video prima da me come
io posso fare video che ha già fatto
prima qualcun altro
c'è gente che può farli dopo che li ho
fatti io non è un problema non andate a
scrivere a certa gente è maturo pippa
lee j perché fai video sugli stessi
videogiochi che fa lui no assolutamente
ognuno è libero di fare quello che vuole
perché youtube eno community libera e
assolutamente io non me la prenderei mai
per una cosa del genere ed è una
grandissima stronzata anche questa non
scrivete a nessuno che qualcuno copia da
me prossimo domanda allora ciao farvi
una domanda per il blog vele pesante
registrare tutti questi video ogni
giorno ossia
ma sì allora ci dedico veramente tanto
tempo e vidal giorno io ci dedico 45 ore
ce le dedico ad un singolo video voi
vedete un video di 10 minuti molti di
voi mi chiedono parli i pali durare un
po di più
ragazzi io per fare un video vi giuro ci
metto un eternità ci metto 45 ore un'ora
per la registrazione e il 3 o 4 ore per
l'editing raga ci metto tantissimo anche
per fare questo ci ha commesso questo
tempo qui è un sacrificio che faccio
perché voglio che vi miei video ogni mio
viso esca bene lo sapete se mi seguite
che io questa filosofia ogni video deve
essere perfetto e quindi se non è
perfetto piuttosto non lo metto neanche
salto un giorno ma se ogni mio video non
è perfetto non lo metto 15 m tantissimo
tempo a quando mi vide e mi piace sapere
di farvi divertire piuttosto ci metto
anche tutto questo tempo però sappiate
che ci dedico tutto questo tempo perché
ci tengo che siano perfetti vabbè ma vi
pensi che rimarrai sempre legati giochi
per principe ripe video oppure pensi di
allargarmi allargarti tra qualche mese a
quelli pre console magari anche dopo
l'uscita ds4 si allora ho pensato di
fare di hardy pare video su altre
piattaforme
ve lo dico subito perché aspettatevi
faccio vedere
eccoli ci sono allora molti rimarranno
sorpresi di questo però va beh lo faccio
lo stesso the last of us ce l'ho anch'io
allora il principio avevo comprato della
stoffa perché volevo volevo fare una
serie the last hope aldo perché non l'ho
fatto perché allora ho registrato un ora
di le vasto cose sono due o tre episodi
avevo registrato non gli ho mai messi
per un semplice motivo raga ho scoperto
che questo genere di giochi diciamo che
i videogame tranquilli c'è tranquilli
nel senso che in più narrativi più nel
quale bisogna seguirla storia non sono
nella mia indole di youtuber quindi
evito di iniziarli comunque dell'altro
pato è un grandissimo videogame
vi consiglio di prendere se avete una
ps3 perché è fantastico quindi ragazzi
di risposta la domanda di prima 6
videogiochi
anche su ps4 ps3 sui su qualsiasi
piattaforma di quelli del pci si saranno
compatibili col mio stile di vita perché
no assolutamente sì
quindi farò video anche al di fuori del
pc sicuramente la cosa è nata la tua
passione per i videogiochi di
conseguenza su youtube
allora la mia voglia di fare video su
youtube è nata come avevo detto nel draw
my life
circa due anni fa io non faccio video su
youtube da sette mesi anche perché molti
dicono hai raggiunto successo in un
tempo incredibile
sì è vero perché comunque sette mezzi
sette mesi in centomila scritti noi
siamo infatti nessuno in italia penso
quindi ragazzi una cosa impressionante
grazie ancora un altro grazie mi
uccidete vabbè comunque è una cosa che è
nata con nicolas e luca che era che sono
due miei amici abbiamo aperto un canale
insieme per divertimento perché eravamo
appassionati siamo appassionati di
videogiochi è niente da lì abbiamo
deciso di niente fare video insieme
cerca di fare commenta l'insieme ed è
durato per un anno e mezzo questa cosa
poi ho aperto il mio canale perché molti
seguivano soltanto me persa la storia
comunque ho iniziato insieme con gli
amici per divertimento alessandro neri
vi chiede parigi e domanda lavori fatti
a sempre ma quando grilli per gli
spaventi mentre giochi l'horror i tuoi
genitori non ti dicono niente che cosa
ne pensano nella tua carriera da
youtuber tissimo continua così allora è
questa che sono argomento discutibile da
quando faccio video su youtube per
questo canale che tenga un po di tono di
voce alto fare i video quando i miei
sono in casa è un problema perché io non
mi sono mai abituato a questa cosa io
cerco di far vi dò sempre quando i
genitori sono fuori casa infatti ci sono
delle volte in cui i genitori non sono a
casa che mi si tuffa sul computer appena
escono po pochino una porta mi lancio
sul computer
vabbè però comunque miei genitori mi
sento né mi vergogno anche perché a
volte quando grido penso cazzo nostro
figlio che lo abbiamo sbagliato che
grida lo abbiamo cresciuto male ma vabbè
grido spesso quando ci sono loro
preferiscono un partito li faccio poi
quando non ci sono comunque è un
problema sappiatelo questo è sempre
stato un problema ma cerco di
ritagliarmi gli spazi con uno ci sono
perché leggerai questo commento ballando
la macarena loro domanda ti riconoscono
per strada
sì mi è capitato più volte di essere
riconosciuto per strada qui a torino e
ho dovuto firmare autografi io non so
firmare ragazzi è una cosa veramente
oscena comunque infatti ci sono rimasto
più volte quando mi hanno fermato mi
hanno detto che j
vabbè è una cosa molto strana comunque
sì ho dovuto mi hanno fermato più volte
si cosi 2008 ti ritieni cambiato da
quando iniziato a fare video su youtube
via d'oro
allora questo nel tuo punto che vorrei
prendere un attimo non mi ritengo
cambiato da quel iniziato a fare video
su youtube e questa è la mia filosofia
di video da youtube più che dividono non
cambierò mai il mio stile di video
perché ho visto prima di diventare uno
youtuber seguivo molti più tubero ho
visto moltissima gente perdersi nel
corso del loro le cose la loro carriera
da youtube
li ho visti cambiare in tanto tantissimo
visto cambiare questa è una cosa che non
farò mai
se per caso un giorno vedete è ma fa
vigili non è più quello di una volta
ditemelo subito perché non dove non deve
mai succedere
l'unica cosa che è cambiata da quando
iniziato da quando ho iniziato a fare
video su youtube che sono diventato più
molti di voi l'hanno notato questo dando
i miei video vecchi sono diventato più
diciamo preso più confidenza sono più
socievole sono più attivo in poche
parole sono meno
meno triste perché prima facendo così
bella a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuta in
questo nuovo video sono fa vj oggi siamo
su china rottura di palle assurda quindi
sono cambiato nel senso che sono
diventato più ho preso più confidenza
con voi con youtube in generale quindi
sono più divertente dal punto di vista
quello che dico sono più spigliato però
per quanto riguarda essere cambiato nel
senso esso si sono montati la testa
essere cambiato aver cambiato il senso
no assolutamente mai successa una cosa
del genere mi sparo poi all'inizio i
sotto bulbosa lo charme e nello script
all
carmen de ros scelto sempre tutti i
pokémon di fuoco 10 guai a concepire
veramente quante persone sono iscritte
al tuo canale no ecco anche questa è una
cosa fantastica
allora adesso questo momento mentre sto
facendo blog
vado a vedere perché non mi ricordo
non lo so perché non so compratore lee
smith in testa vabbè comunque siamo
97.300 16 ragazzi non riesco a
concepirlo nel senso che io leggo quel
numerino lì ma non
la mia mente non c'è se io mi metto se
mi mettessero davanti a 97.000 persone e
più di 97.000 persone a fare quello che
faccio tutti i giorni con la webcam è
livido non ci riuscirei mai ma non
riuscire mai neanche davanti a 50
persone ma neanche a 10 perché mi
vergognerei da morire cioè dieci persone
riguardano mentre faccio quello che mi
guarda mezza italia anzi cioè finire
addirittura in home page di youtube fare
una caduta dove ci si spacca una rotula
in un video di youtube mentre ti vede
tutta la nazione è una cosa assurda
mentre io non farei un video davanti a
10 persone perché mi vergognerei con un
cane per dire no realizzo quanti ne ho
c'è quello per me è un numero ma io devo
ancora realizzare ma non riesco mai a
realizzare perché a 21 sempre di più
rughe in sintesi non non realizzo quanti
siamo assolutamente prima che realizzi
ci vuole del tempo e non so neanche
quanto fai le coop condivido trumbull
axen allora raga anche questa domanda
volevo risponderci perché mi avete
chiesto in tantissimi di pollo
ultimamente me lo hanno chiesto anche
loro ovviamente
purtroppo in questo periodo non ci sono
perché non riesco a incastrarmi con
nessuno di loro con gli orari
perché quando ci sono io non ci sono
loro è riuscito a discussione perché
dicevano che non gli rispondeva cioè non
è che dicevano loro voi pensavate che
non rispondesse alle loro domande ma non
è così è perché diciamo che ogni volta
mi mandava un messaggio per chiedermi se
volevo fare una coop
il messaggio veniva sommerso dalla
valanga di messaggi mary ogni giorno
perché ogni giorno ragazzi voi non
immaginate quanti messaggi ma arrivano
ne volete un esempio bene vi faccio gli
screening dei messaggi di youtube e di
facebook allora questi sono quelli
youtube e questi sono quelli di facebook
allora laga quello che vedete su
facebook sono i messaggi non letti cioè
quelli che devo ancora leggere pensate
voi e sono quelli settimanali cioè
settimanalmente mi arrivano questo
numero di messaggi stessa cosa per
quello di youtube sono oltre mille
quelli non aperti non quelli che ho
aperto quindi ragazzi questo non solo
per loro ma anche per voi che mi mandate
messaggi ogni tanto se non rispondo non
prendetevela non è che allora non è che
io sto snobbando che mi faccio il divo
che mi faccio il figo è ma io al 97 mila
fan non risponde alla gente no
assolutamente questo significherebbe che
sono cambiato come ho detto prima
no io una volta rispondeva a tutti i
messaggi che mi mandavano ma perché
erano contenute invece nel senso che
potevo farlo però ultimamente me ne
stanno arrivando i valanghe al giorno me
ne arrivano troppi veramente tantissimi
saranno forse tre quattrocento c'è una
cosa impressionante
quindi quando vi accolgono in un
messaggio loro magari mi hanno inviato
una settimana primavera con una
settimana dopo
ma comunque non ci sarà buio letti con
messaggi o anche disposto recentemente
stamattina perché mi hanno mandato una
settimana fa però purtroppo non posso
fare coop con nessuno di loro perché in
questo periodo non sono a casa sono
fuori casa e quindi niente ragazzi mi
spiace non posso fare coppia si vedrà
poi a fine agosto quando saremo tutti a
casa
se la scuola non sarà un problema per
tutti quanti quindi ragazzi con questo
video spero di aver risposto alla
maggioranza delle domande è quella che
mi chiedevate di più in quest'ultimo
periodo comunque ragazzi per questo
video la concludo qui sei video è più
giusto come al solito chateau argomento
mi piace anche la pagina di facebook
come noi video trovate nella descrizione
sede senatur i siti iscrivete che non ci
vediamo un prossimo vito belle ragazze